[Música]
ahora bienvenidos a este primer programa
de revista digital de 2021 donde
seguimos abordando los temas más
importantes del ciberespacio y las redes
sociales y los medios de comunicación de
américa latina y el mundo sin twitter ni
facebook o instagram
el presidente de donaldson perdió el
acceso a sus redes sociales las grandes
tecnológicas también vetaron de su
espacio a movimientos cuentas y hasta
aplicaciones desde las que se promueve
el apoyo al mandatario alegando que no
tolerarán publicaciones que incitan a la
violencia pero estas medidas han
reavivado un interminable debate hasta
donde estas compañías pueden regular
este tipo de contenidos sin que eso de
monitoreo derive en una violación al
derecho a la libertad de expresión
empezamos citando un riesgo de una mayor
incitación a la violencia twitter el
megáfono favorito del presidente de
donald trump suspendió permanentemente
la cuenta del mandatario la medida se
aplicó tras el asalto al capitolio de
eeuu que cobró la vida de 5 personas
hacia allí trauma instó a marchar a sus
seguidores mientras el congreso
certificaba la victoria de joe biden al
día de hoy son más de 10 tecnológicas
que han restringido a trump
partidarios entre ellas facebook snap
chat y youtube parler una red social
popular entre los conservadores y donde
tienen fuerte presencia grupos de
extrema derecha fue sacada de las
tiendas de aplicaciones de google y
apple por no moderar las publicaciones
de sus usuarios una medida que su
fundador calificó como una motivación
política el propietario de twitter jack
dorsey dijo que no celebra ni se siente
orgulloso de haber suspendido a la
cuenta del presidente de donald trump y
aunque dijo que fue la decisión correcta
reconoció que representa un fracaso de
su parte para promover una conversación
saludable tener que tomar estas acciones
fragmentar la conversación pública nos
dividen limitan el potencial de
aclaración redención y aprendizaje y
sienta un precedente que considero
peligroso el poder que un individuo
corporación tiene sobre una parte de la
conversación pública global las redes
sociales siempre han sido criticadas por
no tomar medidas contundentes para
regular el contenido que se mueve en sus
plataformas publicaciones dañinas
discursos de odio y desinformación y
ahora que decidieron restringir a trump
el tema divide aguas y atiza el debate
sobre si al modo
esos contenidos las redes sociales se
están tomando atribuciones sobre qué se
puede decir y qué no
lina patiño analista digital cree que
internet necesita una regulación más
poderosa en este momento le estamos
exigiendo a plataformas privadas como
son facebook twitter u otras redes
sociales que actúen como organismos de
control y que diriman un poco el debate
público en una esfera que en últimas es
privada y déjame darte un ejemplo si
esto se tratara de algo como un
restaurante entrar a un restaurante a
gritar cosas y el dueño del restaurante
saca a trump porque está violando las
normas de convivencia dentro de ese
restaurante no estaríamos teniendo esta
discusión frente a la libertad de
expresión porque estaríamos de acuerdo
con que hay otras esferas en las que
trump podría manifestarse una plaza
pública un parque y demás sin embargo en
el mundo digital esto parece haberse
confundido y lo que todo este enredo
alrededor del debate de libertad de
expresión y las redes sociales y quien
sí y que no puede ser censurado por así
decirlo
alrededor de la falta de regulación que
tenemos del mundo virtual y del poco
entendimiento que tenemos sobre hasta
dónde va el negocio y hasta dónde va el
ágora pública y la libertad de expresión
de todos unos a los usuarios que estamos
allí pero la primera enmienda de la
constitución de eeuu sólo se prohíbe al
gobierno interferir en la libertad de
expresión y no menciona a empresas
privadas por eso consultamos a ana ojeda
abogada especialista en derecho procesal
civil y nuevas tecnologías
definitivamente cuando hablamos de
libertad de expresión debemos reconocer
que es un derecho fundamental no
solamente un derecho consagrado en la
primera enmienda en los eeuu
norteamérica sino que es un derecho
universal es decir cubre o llega a todos
los ciudadanos en estos momentos la
libertad de expresión en internet ha
sido un poco
digamos que malinterpretar porque las
personas suelen creer que tener libertad
de expresión es poder ir una red social
o cualquier plataforma nos vamos a
olvidar de twitter supongamos facebook o
depronto blogs foto cualquier otro sitio
donde podamos interactuar y pueda decir
lo que te dé la gana lo que te venga en
gana y si alguien te aplica una política
en este caso una sanción por
incumplimiento inmediatamente que dice
las personas no lo que pasa es que no
respetan mi derecho a la libertad de
expresión o están censura los líderes
mundiales también han tomado parte en
esta discusión en una entrevista al
washington post la comisaria de
competencia de la unión europea y quien
ha buscado limitar el poder de las
grandes tecnológicas reconoció que fue
una situación extrema y que se cruzaron
las líneas pero también se preguntó por
qué estas redes sociales tardaron tanto
en excluir al presidente de sus
plataformas
el presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador dijo que no está de
acuerdo en que nadie sea censurado
mientras que a través de su portavoz la
canciller alemana angela merkel dijo que
veía dicha situación como problemática
los medios de comunicación se han
adelantado a lo que sucedería si las
redes sociales siguen por este camino y
vice news titula que la prohibición de
trump en twitter genera preocupaciones
sobre el poder desenfrenado de las
grandes tecnológicas varios portales
como newsweek han citado un comunicado
de la unión estadounidense por las
libertades civiles que dice que
suspender acción de las redes sociales
podría sentar un precedente para que las
grandes empresas tecnológicas silencia
en voces menos privilegiadas un artículo
del new york times dice que acciones
como ésta también plantean interrogantes
a más largo plazo como si los modelos de
negocio de las empresas de redes
sociales son fundamentalmente
compatibles con una democracia sana si
en bici expone que otra de las preguntas
clave es si estas empresas deberían ser
tratadas como editores en lugar de
empresas tecnológicas lo que significa
que sería más responsables del contenido
disponible en sus plataformas
recordemos que la sección 230 de la ley
de decencia de las comunicaciones
sección era a estas compañías de ser
responsables del contenido creado por
sus usuarios hasta aquí y revista
digital recuerde que si quiere repetir
esta u otra emisión de nuestro programa
lo puede hacer a través de nuestra
página web www puntos 24 punto com
[Música]